un ennemi invisible un ennemi qui le
premier pas essentiel qui ne connaît que
la brutalité qui est là en concert dumas
mais grâce à notre détermination nous
sommes en train d'y faire face on a le
sentiment c'est une guerre perpétuelle
dans le sel contre les terroristes
quel est votre constat la menace et le
risque d'une menace pour vos bas et que
sa réponse également doit être plus
souvent delà de la solidarité
robin
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
elle est l'une jérôme rodriguez
interpellés lors d'un rassemblement
interdit par la préfecture de police la
figure d gilet jaune dénonce des
violences policières à son encontre
vous l'entendrez témoigner dans cette
édition à part il avait rejoint le
cortège des antifa mobilisés du côté de
montparnasse contre les manifestants
ration identitaire à denfert rochereau
le groupe anti immigration menacée de
dissolution par gérald darmanin les
alpes-maritimes en alerte rouge le
variant britannique qui circule
activement ce matin olivier ferrand
s'est déplacé à vis de ministre de la
santé n'exclut pas dû renforcer les
restrictions talus
pourrait s'agir d'un couvre-feu accentué
d'un confinement partiel ou total dans
huit à dix jours emmanuel macron devrait
dire c'est le relâche ou au contraire
resserre les mesures sanitaires ailleurs
sur le territoire
[Musique]
et puis en russie double sanction pour
alexeï navalni l'opposant russe a été
reconnu coupable de diffamation d'un
vétéran de la seconde guerre mondiale a
par ailleurs un tribunal de moscou a
confirmé en appel une sentence de prison
ferme une peine initiale avec sursis
prononcée en 2014 pour multiples
violation de son contrôle judiciaire
dans le cadre d'une affaire de
détournement de compte
[Musique]
bonsoir à tous bienvenue si vous nous
rejoignez sur rt france ans on commence
avec ce face à face à distance à paris
aujourd'hui qui n'a pas duré longtemps
d'un côté génération identitaire s'est
mobilisée pour dénoncer une éventuelle
dissolution à la demande du ministre de
l'intérieur et de l'autre une contre
manifestation de l'ultra gauche
interdite et disperser rapidement
retour sur cette journée avec cyrielle
benavides bullion sur la place denfert
rochereau
il est 14h et déjà des centaines de
militants brandissent des drapeaux bleus
et des banderoles
ce sont les membres de génération
identitaire ils se sont réunis pour
s'opposer à la procédure de dissolution
engagée par le ministre de l'intérieur
gérald darmanin le 14 février et selon
les porte parole du mouvement
cette procédure n'a pas lieu d'être nous
voulions rappeler l'importance de la
liberté d'expression et la liberté
d'association dans ce pays qui sont
actuellement gravement mises à mal par
le gouvernement et par un gérald
darmanin particuliers qui souhaitent 10
ou deux générations identitaire pour des
raisons bassement politiques d'une part
mais aussi à travers nos finalement il
ya une volonté de criminaliser le
discours anti immigration dans ce pays
or on peut encore à être hostile à
l'immigration en france sans que ce ne
soit ni condamnable ni motif de
dissolution tout simplement que
juridiquement parlant à gérald darmanin
n'a pas les outils pour 10 ou deux
générations identitaire cette lettre de
qui a annoncé notre dissolution elle
s'appuie sur des chefs d'accusation qui
était la constitution de milices d'une
part et l'incitation à la haine
sachant qu'en fait pour l'opération que
nous avions menée dans les alpes en 2018
où nous avions déployé une bande une
frontière symbolique entre la france et
l'italie
nous avions eu un procès pour
effectivement constitution de milices et
nous avons été relaxé par la justice en
décembre dernier donc la justice elle a
déjà tranché pour pour ce chef
d'accusation là et en ce qui concerne la
situation allait nous n'avons jamais été
condamnée non plus pour ce chef
d'accusation nous n'avons jamais eu de
procédure judiciaire et où les propos
que nous avons jamais pu tenir ont
toujours respecté le cadre de la loi et
la liberté d'expression en parallèle un
contre rassemblement de collectifs et
d'associations de l'ultra gauche avait
lieu à montparnasse
pour protester contre la mobilisation de
génération identitaire un regroupement
que la préfecture n'avait pas autorisé
car la demande aurait été adressée je
cite trop tardivement
les forces de l'ordre venues en grand
nombre n'ont pas perdu de temps pour
disperser la manifestation au grand dam
de ses militants antifa génération
identitaire a le droit de manifester et
les antifascistes
non voilà donc l'allemand a été de plus
en plus clair en effet voilà tu
constates sas et je trouve ça absolument
dommageable pour la démocratie en france
histoire dont il pas autoriser cette
manifestation est autorisée génération
identitaire qui est en passe d'être
dissous si on doit entendre dernière
voie avant qu'on les entend plus
pourquoi pas tant qu'ils sont dissous
comme dérange pas et vous en faites ce
qu'il faut voir c'est le résultat
ils manifestent on ne manifeste pas
c'est pas c'est pas ça le prévenu ce
qu'on dise ou non encore là et c'est le
service d'accueil parce que tout a été
instrumentalisée que maintenant les
médias ils sont à droite que voilà
laisser news tout ça ils manipulent
l'information et que je reviens aux
antilles fin on a l'impression que oui
mais voilà comme budget c'est les
méchants marché est vraiment ce que ça
veut dire elle est méchant mais c'est
que les gens ils sont tous à l'image de
nous et horvàth et je trouve ça dommage
parce que nous on est pas on n'est pas
là pour faire du mal ou quoi jeter mon
nom ce pas contre le fascisme
je pense que le combat à l'origine il a
il a lieu d'être et
il est censé la dissolution du groupe
génération identitaire créé en 2012 a
été évoqué pour la première fois le 26
janvier par gérald darmanin l'actuel
locataire de la place beauvau s'était
dit scandalisé par une opération anti
migrants que le groupe avait mené dans
les pyrénées une opération musclée qui
n'était pas sans rappeler l'expulsion de
migrants le 23 novembre 2020 au soir
place de la république par les forces de
l'ordre
et puis cette interpellation musclée
loin d'être passé inaperçu celle de
jérôme rodriguez le gilet jaune avaient
rejoint le cortège de la
contre-manifestation elle cela s'est
passé du côté de la place du 18 juin
1940 il revient sur son interpellation
micro d'rtl france et annonce porter
plainte pour violences policières et
séquestration dans les côtes
le plus incroyable c'est qu'ils nous ont
laissé passer et accéder à la place
quelques minutes après j'entends dans
les talkie walkie mon nom résonner comme
quoi ma ma position est signalé à
l'ensemble des forces de police on leur
répond dans le talkie walkie que oui oui
on l'a bien en vue trois minutes après
vous avez la brave qui débarque et qui
veut une fois de plus
nous verbaliser nous nous maltraiter
nous empêcher de manifester bref
d'appliquer cette discrimination
politique aujourd'hui donc dont je suis
victime et dont l'ensemble des citoyens
en colère et gilet jaune sont victimes
aujourd'hui discrimination politique
je suis libre je vais être reconvoquée
en audition libre à savoir que j'ai été
violenté pendant mon interpellation j'ai
trois jours d'itt été déclaré par le
médecin ils m'ont fait mal aux mains ils
m'ont excusez moi mais écrasé les
testicules pendant pendant l'arrestation
et quoi qu'il arrive nous allons porter
plainte à la fois pour violences
policières séquestration et est comment
dire atteinte à la liberté de enfin
atteinte à ma liberté tout simplement
quoi et ça c'est pas la première fois
que ça arrive ça déjà arrivé un 14
juillet de dessus bien ce sont des gens
qui sont au service du maintien du
désordre et non pas au maintien de
l'ordre
donc aujourd'hui il faut arrêter avec
ces voltigeurs quand on sait que par le
passé ils ont su tuer des gens qu'est ce
qu'on attend
on va recommencer on attend qu'il y ait
un mort de la part de cette police et on
en parle tout de suite avec aymeric
glisser les secrétaire général adjoint
des think tanks le millénaire bonsoir
merci d'être avec nous en direct sur rt
france
alors d'abord vous avez entendu jérôme
rodriguez qui est interpellé de façon
musclée ils l'expliquent
il avait rejoint le cortège des
contre-manifestants qui faisait face
donc ça n'a pas duré longtemps à une
manifestation de génération identitaire
sur cette journée précisément votre
analyse
alors tout d'abord il n'y a pas de
violences policières
si il y à des actes sont isolés ils sont
sanctionnés minoritaires et systémique
sur la police d'avoir rappelé le soutien
aux forces de l'ordre qui exactement
mais telle une situation très compliquée
on l'a revu encore cette semaine avec le
gall d'ataka à poissy donc le site les
propos qu' une de monsieur richesse de
nos langages que lui qui aura une
enquête a priori suite à ses
déclarations et qui portent plainte mais
là je vais rappeler que très solidaire
des dépôts volant qui a lancé une
mission une mission très compliquée
difficile aux côtés
sur la mêlée est à son d'aujourd'hui
locales de génération identitaire et la
contre-manifestation la manifestation
contre une perte à sion ou à des entités
a été interdite par le par le préfet par
le préfet de police tu donc c'est normal
que cette manifestation ne se soient pas
tenues l'essentiel est de préserver
l'autorité et l'ordre par whoopi comment
une manifestation qui est un territoire
aient pu se tenir alors même de gros
risques de débordements et on l'a
potentiellement vu lorsqu'il ya eu une à
rapprochement et forme de contact entre
générations identitaire et les antifas
c'était c'était important j'ai toujours
d'éviter des accrochages et des faits
qui auraient pu être dit l'amour qui va
peut être relativement violent mais sur
les images quand même que l'on a vues
pour revenir à l'interpellation quand
même d'un jérôme rodriguez même dans le
cadre d'une manifestation non autorisée
quel regard vous portez sur la manière
dont lui a été justement à interpeller
ne trouvez pas que c'est un petit peu
excessif la manifestation était
interdite je fais toute confiance aux
forces de l'ordre qui exercent qui
exercent leur métier pour justement
éviter une situation qu'il faut le
rappeler était très très à risque avec
des annonces d'affrontements et des
appels lance kabylité qui avait été
porté de brossard comptait côté de
l'extrême gauche allait convoquer cette
inscription d'extrême droite je pense
que le l'essentiel a été préservé
on peut se rappeler il ya scènes
d'émeutes et de chaos nous avons vécu à
l'automne dernier avec des antilles fans
des black blocks ravagé le mobilier
urbain où on avait des scènes deux quasi
guerre civile dans paris moi je me
réjouis que ce soir et on n'a pas eu ce
genre de scène aujourd'hui
justement le l'ordre ring la
manifestation qui se déroulait dans le
calme sur génération identitaire menacé
de dissolution par gérald darmanin là
votre analyse
je trouve que gérald darmanin et fort
avec les faibles et faible avec les
forts
c'est à dire qu'on a un qui est plutôt
plutôt pacifique qui amène un sur le
débat la question
laquelle elle sur le début de la
question de l'immigration et on va
préférer plutôt s'attaquer à ce groupe
s'il amène une question qui appelle le
débat puisque 78% des français estiment
qu'il faudrait passer une immigration
subie vers une immigration choisie donc
il est besoin de débattre de cette
question de reprendre le contrôle de
notre politique migratoire choisir
quelques teams rapport aux normes en vue
d'appliquer et on a le sentiment que
finalement on veut supprimer le débat
sur cette question là pour en faire
disparaître les problèmes les
interrogations alors que ça ne réglera
strictement rien dire
est ce qu'il est dans son rôle est-ce
que génération identitaire est dans son
rôle lorsqu'elle ya des actions anti néo
grand mener comme ça a été le cas dans
les pyrénées c'est ce que d'ailleurs
reproche le ministre de l'intérieur a à
l'association anti immigration
c'est des actions au point de
communication justement trop car parler
pour l'heure comme ils l'ont appelé
qu'on a pu ce qu'on a pu voir il ya pas
eu de décision de justice les condamne
ans je suis quand même assez assez
étonné dans le même temps que des
générations comme la digue nord
africaine ne soutenez pas été dissoute
alors que les appels à l'été les propos
plus que douteux là c'est un peu un deux
poids deux mesures où finalement
s'attaque à des sons d'extrême droite
mais en même temps on a une forme de
complaisance vis-à-vis des associations
d'extrême gauche
est ce que je vois c'est d'engager les
actions que même génération identitaire
sur le terrain ce qu'elles sont
légitimes
est ce qu'elles sont et ce qu'elles sont
légitimes ou non il y apporte une
réponse du moins ils font entendre une
voix sur la question des migrations sur
le débat qui actuellement d'un pas lieu
c'est ça c'est l'essentiel dans le débat
sur notre politique migratoire il le
fait de reprendre le contrôle de se
doter des outils d'appliquer ou non une
politique migratoire que demain
restrictif donc ce débat là n'aura pas
lieu
mais justement ces actions est long le
bienfait de porter le débat et de
d'essayer de faire parler cette question
là lorsque la pire des réponses essayer
de te mettre cette question là sous le
tapis alors que les français veulent en
débattre veulent apporter des réponses
et ont besoin justement de choisir
l'heure de reprendre
leurs destins de choisir la politique
migratoire est ce que vous pensez que la
dissolution de génération identitaire
peut porter un coup justement au débat
sur l'immigration dans la mesure où ce
n'est qu' un milieu d'un millier
d'adhérents peut-être au noir même
l'association en tant que tel je pense
pas que cela aura de l'impact
spécifiquement mais c'est un coup porté
sur le sur le débat sur la logique dans
quel dans laquelle agit le gouvernement
certaines questions et certains sujets
ne veulent pas être abordés on l'a
notamment vu avec la question de
séparatisme des amendements sur le port
de voile ont été refusées manière
systématique il ya toute une série de
sujets et de thèmes qui sont sciemment
évité je vous conseille de plus
dommageable et la discussion génération
dentaire crible partie de ses actions
qu'ils mènent a avivé le débat
merci beaucoup à vous amérique a glissé
je rappelle que vous êtes à le directeur
de communication du think tank le
secrétaire général partant du secrétaire
général adjoint du think tank le
millénaire voilà merci à vos frais
hier emmanuel macron a fait le point sur
la situation sanitaire avec les
parlementaires de la majorité c'était
lors d'une réunion virtuelle hier soir
cela alors que plusieurs membres de la
république en marche demande la fin de
l'état d'urgence sanitaire prévu en juin
le chef de l'état pourrait décider d'ici
deux semaines un allègement des
contraintes sanitaires c'est des
indicateurs de l'épidémie s'améliore
dans le scénario inverse ce sera un
resserrement l inquiétude c'est vrai
demeure en raison d'une circulation
active des variants justement c'est le
cas dans les alpes maritimes le variant
britannique surtout est ce matin le
ministre de la santé au lit et veyran
était à nice il a jugé la situation sur
place je cite particulièrement
inquiétante les alpes maritimes affiche
le taux d'incidence le plus haut de
france avec 587 personnes infectées sur
une semaine pour 100000 habitants est le
vario anglais du colis de 19 représente
50 % des nouveaux cas selon le préfet du
département et olives et veyran n'exclut
pas un possible confinement partielle ou
totale sur place ces cas positifs
je demande au préfet de continuer la
concertation avec l'ensemble des élus du
territoire pour que d'ici la fin du
week-end nous puissions prendre des
mesures complémentaires de protection de
cette population des alpes maritimes
face à cette flambée épidémique
cela pourrait prendre la forme d'une
accentuation du couvre-feu voire d'un
confinement partielle ou totale et dans
ce contexte sanitaire le gouvernement à
repousser la fin de la trêve hivernale
au 1er juin
pas suffisant pour certains qui souhaite
à tout simplement l'arrêt des expulsions
locatives jusqu'à la fin de l'année et
c'est le cas de michèle picard le maire
communiste de vénissieux en banlieue
lyonnaise
les précisions avec lui ce carvalho et
furan anbar interdire les expulsions
locatives en 2021 dans toute la france
c'est la proposition de la maire de
vénissieux et vice-présidente de la
métropole de lyon dans un courrier
adressé au premier ministre jean castex
michèle picard montent au créneau pour
venir en aide aux plus démunis
alors que la crise sanitaire continue de
battre son plein je trouve que mettre
des gens à la rue sans relogement c'est
inadmissible dans une société comme la
nôtre est encore plus sont prises aux
sanitaires
parce que on sait que les gens qui sont
à la rue sont encore plus sont encore
plus fragilisés
la crise sanitaire a développé aussi une
crise économique une crise sociale sans
nom ce qui fait que du coup on va avoir
de plus en plus de gens et on le voit le
secours populaire
la fondation abbé-pierre toutes ces
associations attire l'attention des
pouvoirs publics sur le sur la précarité
la pauvreté qui s'accentue de jour en
jour
hop même constat du côté de
l'association réseau d'alerté de
solidarité cette association de
vénissieux vient en aide aux personnes
affectées par les ordres d'expulsion
depuis 1997
son président andré mazuir est
catégorique la crise a empiré la
situation de ceux qui étaient déjà en
difficulté la crise économique et la
crise sociale
elle arrivait de toute façon on est en
été en 2019 et il y avait des prémices
pour que cette crise elle éclate la
crise sanitaire qui arrivait en 2020 a
rajouté je rajoutais donc de la
difficulté pour les familles et a permis
effectivement que les choses se
compliquent pour un certain nombre de
familles prévue pour le 1er avril 2021
le gouvernement à repousser la fin de la
trêve hivernale des expulsions locatives
au 1er juin pour permettre aux familles
les plus vulnérables d'affronter une
crise non seulement sanitaire mais aussi
économique et social
on en vient ce scandale lié à la
vaccination anti colis de 19 en
argentine
il est poussé il a poussé le ministre de
la santé a démissionné ce dernier
proposait à ses amis de se faire
injecter des doses dans les locaux de
son ministère elle et précision c'est
avec françois tisci
c'était le monsieur qu'ovide du
gouvernement d' alberto fernandez en
poste depuis 2000 19
le ministre de la santé argentin ginès
gonzalez garcia a démissionné vendredi à
la demande du président une démission
qui fait suite au scandale 10 des
vaccins privilèges
ginette gonzalez garcia proposait en
effet à ses amis de se faire vacciner au
ministère de la santé sans prendre
rendez vous dans un hôpital comme
n'importe quel citoyen s'ensuit alors
une déferlante de réactions sur les
réseaux sociaux
c'est navrant d'entendre les grands
parents à la radio demander de l'aide
pour s'inscrire sur la liste des vaccins
pendant ce temps les politiciens
utilisent leur pouvoir et leurs
privilèges pour se vacciner eux-mêmes et
leurs familles
ma mère à 97 ans est admise dans une
maison de retraite
évidemment sans avoir été vacciné je
suis outré par l'immoralité d'une
vaccination vip espérons que tous les
noms soient connus au total selon la
presse le ministre de la santé se serait
réservé trois mille doses pour sa
défense il avance que les personnes
vaccinées appartenait au groupe inclus
dans la population cible de la campagne
actuelle soit les personnes de plus de
70 ans qui peuvent se faire vacciner
depuis mercredi dans le pays mais selon
les médias argentins
le neveu du ministre de la santé âgée
seulement de 44 ans aurait bénéficié
d'une vaccination avec les premières
doses arrivée à buenos aires est en
décembre dernier des journalistes et
d'autres proches du gouvernement sont
également concernés
ginès gonzalez garcia a été remplacé par
carles à vide zotti spécialiste en
médecine interne est connu pour avoir
négocié le vaccin rue spoutnik v pour
l'argentine avec pour première mission
de faire oublier le scandale des vaccins
privilèges
après ce pic nic v et piva kona corona
place coviva que le nouveau vaccin russe
antique que 8,19 sérum doit passer en
mars la phase iii finale des essais sur
3000 personnes
un remède destinés aux personnes âgées
entre 18 et 60 ans
la russie mène une campagne de
vaccination massive depuis janvier elle
envisage de passer des accords de
production à travers le monde et le pays
l'a annoncé aujourd'hui il fait face aux
premiers cas de transmission de la
nouvelle souche de grippe aviaire à
l'être humain
elle s'agite
virus h5n2 8 sept personnes ont été
infectées dans une usine de volailles
dans le sud du pays
pas de complication relevé à chez les
malades pour l'instant pour le moment ce
variant du virus ne se transmet pas
d'une personne à une autre selon la
présidente de l' agence sanitaire russe
on le rappelle en france à des millions
d'animaux ont déjà été abattus pour
arrêter la progression de la grippe
aviaire
toujours à propos de la russie la
justice maintient l'emprisonnement
d'alexei navalni aujourd'hui l'opposant
russe a été reconnu coupable de
diffamation envers un vétéran de la
seconde guerre mondiale par ailleurs un
tribunal de moscou a confirmé en appel
une sentence de prison ferme et les
précisions de notre correspondante à
moscou vera goffman alexeï navalni a été
reconnu coupable par un tribunal russe
ce 20 février de 10 fermes à sion d'un
ancien combattant de la seconde guerre
mondiale et a été condamné à une amende
de 850 mille roubles soit près de 9500
euros
en prononçant sa décision la juge a pris
en considération l'état de santé de
navalni et le fait qu'il a deux enfants
alexeï navalni n'a pas reconnu sa
culpabilité estime que les poursuites
avaient été lancées sans fondement légal
le posant a mis en ligne le 2 juin sur
télégramme et twitter une vidéo dans
laquelle le vétéran de la seconde guerre
mondiale ignacio minko exprimé son
soutien aux amendements la constitution
navalni était accusé d'avoir formulé des
commentaires erronés portant atteinte à
l'honneur et à la réputation du vétéran
dans la matinée je vous rappelle la
justice russe avait confirmé que la
peine de prison avec sursis prononcée
contre alexeï navalni en 2014 dans l'
affaire de détournement de fonds dans la
filiale russe du groupe français yves
rocher était transformée en cinq ans
ferme navale ne s'étaient pas présentés
à l'enregistrement auprès de
l'inspection pénitentiaire à six
reprises au cours de l'année 2020 il
s'agit de la période
avant son empoisonnement présumé en août
le tribunal a toutefois légèrement
réduit dans mois et demi sa condamnation
et l'opposant devra finalement purger
une peine de deux ans et demi de prison
les avocats d'alexa navalni et vont
faire appel de cette décision auprès de
la cour de cassation
et l'avocate alexeï navalni est bien
décidé à faire appel je vous propose de
l'écouter
bien sûr que nous allons faire appel en
plus nous n'avons même pas encore reçu
la sentence le tribunal a déclaré qu'il
nous l'a délivrerait dans cinq jours
je doute qu'on puisse le transférer ou
même le détenir dans un centre de
détention provisoire puisqu'on n'a pas
encore la sentence du tribunal lui-même
n'a pas eu accès à cette sentence ni le
convoi pénitencier ni ses avocats
quel est donc le fondement de sa
détention en ce moment c'est
incompréhensible
cette nouvelle journée de manifestations
en birmanie plusieurs centaines de
policiers sont intervenus sur un
chantier naval de mandales et la
deuxième ville du pays
cela après un coup d'état le 1er février
dernier contre au centre succi des
manifestants se sont alors interposés
mais la police aurait ouvert le feu
selon les secouristes présents sur place
deux manifestants ont été tués dont un
mineur et une trentaine de blessés sont
à déplorer
le chef de la diplomatie européenne josé
thorel condamne les violences sont
commises par les militaires
je condamne fermement la violence contre
des manifestants civils pacifiques par
les militaires j'exhorte l'armée et
toutes les forces de sécurité en
birmanie à mettre fin immédiatement aux
violences contre les civils
nous discuterons lundi des derniers
événements birmanie pour prendre les
décisions appropriées
demain à la présidentielle au niger à
deuxième tour une élection dans un
contexte sécuritaire attendu le candidat
du parti au pouvoir mohamed bazoum est
donné favori après être arrivé en tête à
l'issue du premier tour son adversaire
l'ex président du niger mamadou ousmane
sow scrutin pourrait être la première
transition démocratique dans l'histoire
du pays on voit cela avec race d'aliens
des affiches de campagne qui inondent
les rues à niamey la capitale
ici les élections sont attendues avec
hâte et c'est dans un contexte
sécuritaire tendu avec des attaques
djihadistes récurrente que doit se tenir
ce dimanche le second tour des poloïstes
c'est ça les grands problèmes de
sécurité à l'époque de toul ici on a des
voiles du châtel qui fait pâlir agadez
et point afrique go voyages chaque
semaine trois mois par an tout le monde
travaille tout le monde
les artisanes les agences de voyages
grand favori mohamed bazoum bras droit
du président mahamadou issoufou est
arrivé en tête du premier tour avec 39 %
des voix un candidat qui ne laisse
présager que peu de changements dans la
politique du pays
ce que critique vivement son opposant
ancien président de la république du
niger et du en 1993 si monsieur bové qui
prône la continuité mais les gens n'ont
pas de doux à vue de conclure non plus
deux comme à gémir le changement c'est
pourtant ce que cherche la majorité des
nigériens des piroguiers paye un million
cinq cent mille francs cfa soit plus de
2000 euros pour l'éducation de ses
enfants qui ne juge pas à la hauteur en
matière de santé et de pouvoir d'achat
même bilan pour nos économies qu'ils
pouvaient et tout le monde est malade
sans médicaments hôpital girone ça coûte
cher les produits ça coûte cher
non ça les troisièmes pour vivre pour
manger même un sac de mil
aujourd'hui ça fait au moins 23 min
toutefois le peuple nigérien et rassurer
le président mahamadou issoufou fait le
pari démocratique en laissant la main de
la présidence
c'est l'exemple des membres de se voir
des chefs d'état africains qui a donné
un modèle vraiment pour moi c'est un
modèle vais donner cet exemple aux
africains
des briguer des mandats et après les
selles et si mohamed bazoum semble avoir
une longueur d'avancé
l'expérience de l'ex président mahamane
ousmane à des postes clés du continent
africain président du parlement de la
cedeao ou du comité interparlementaire
sur les droits de l'homme de l'union
économique et monétaire ouest africaine
des postes qui pourrait peut-être lui
conférer une vision globale et
sécuritaire plus offensive que son
prédécesseur effet la fin de ce journal
merci à vous de l'avoir suivi on va se
retrouver à tout à l'heure dans 30
minutes
restez avec nous sur rp france
[Musique]
c'est chacun pour soi dieu pour tous tes
pieds coup politique n'a jamais été
obligé de dire la vérité
les ide et courageuse des mots qui
comptent la haine en soi vient de
l'ignorance au genou gauche l'extrême